there's nothing quite like curling up on
the sofa and marathoning Netflix's fine
film selection these are just a few of
the flakes that deserved way more
attention than they're getting part
apocalyptic thriller part family drama
the Ellen Page in Evan Rachel Wood led
into the forest as a compelling and
settling movie that never quite goes
with a viewer things that's going deep
inside a beautiful remote forests as
sisters Nell and Eva live in a Staley
window covered home with their father
played by Callum Keith Rene there's been
a far reaching collapse of the National
Grid but Nell and Eva continued to live
their lives as best they can until the
power comes back spoiler alerts it
doesn't time passes agonizingly the food
and supply reserves dwindle and some
truly horrific things happen as Nell and
Eva far from civilization wonder if
society has completely collapsed and
fight for the lives they once took for
granted
eventually they can't wait around
anymore I must fend for themselves by
heading into the forest the occasional
bad gig is a necessary stumbling block
for a young band paying us Jews but here
assault green room isn't a spinal tap
Aska comedy about the indignities
musicians face let me call my cousin I
can get you guys a solid gig we're here
seems dead get down close to the
Portland instead it's a claustrophobic
intense and at times horrific post
pounder about a regular punk band whose
members include Imogen Poots alia
Shawkat and the late Anton Yelchin who
get waylaid and trapped in the green
room the backstage waiting area of a
concert venue surprise it turns out the
place is actually a Nazi skinhead bar
and one of the musicians just so
happened to catch a glimpse of the body
of a recently murdered woman as a
results the bad guys hold the band
hostage until they can kill them their
leader is the worst of all portrayed by
a very much against tight Patrick
Stewart needless to say he steals the
spotlights well he steals it and he
stomps it to pieces it's an intense
compelling low-budget horror movie of a
different stripe and one from which not
everyone gets out alive or intact over
the last decade or so the Chinese film
industry has exploded producing big
movies on par with Hollywood
blockbusters and as the Western Canon
provide
to rich history of fantasy take the Lord
of the Rings for example so to diss
China with no villain a sprawling 30
book series written by multiple authors
that concerns a made up quasi medieval
and magical universe legend of the Nagas
pearls marks Nova lands auspicious us
streaming debut the story is set the
mythical city of year Annapolis where
ho-hum humans and the angel like winged
tribal live side by side but not without
some hostility of course a war between
the races led to the dominance of the
humans and the wind tribe losing its
flying abilities the movie picks up with
an understandably angry descendant of
the most royal of the winged tribe
played by Simon Lam going on an
adventure to locate the fabled Naga
pearls which would destroy the humans
once and for all
those pearls however accidentally wind
up in the possession of a human prince
constable and thief
and they do everything they can to keep
them out of their enemy's hands a
process which involves epic battles and
dazzling fight and flight sequences
that'll turn even the most jaded viewer
into a fun for life the only in the 70s
film genre known as blaxploitation hip
fight sequence loaded action rights
featuring predominantly african-american
casts spoofed in loving detail in black
Dynamite's a quirky compelling and
extremely hilarious midnight movie
co-writer and star Michael Jai White
shows off his impressive martial art
skills film history knowledge and
ability to crack the perfect one-liners
as the titular Black Dynamite a one-man
army and ex CIA operative now set on
single-handedly fixing some problems
both personal and societal by going
after the man who is the man pure evil
what with how he killed black Dynamite's
brother wants to get orphans addicted to
drugs and introduced an extra-strong a
malt liquor into the black community
that shrinks the male reproductive organ
the plot is totally over the top in its
adventure inspired by shaft and Superfly
except those flicks unfortunately don't
have any scenes set on kung fu Island or
mistakes throwed in on purpose to make
the movie look like a homemade labor of
love dynamite
[Music]